well it's lovely to see here states talk
about crossing lines and for fans you
know your work so well are many things
films and TV but for prison break fans
in particular how would you compare
crossing lines in your character in the
show I have been asked about comparisons
with the characters and yes the both
characters are police officers and
incredibly good at what they what they
do both characters have a bit of a
substance abuse problem so but I really
think the similarities kind of kind of
been there they they live fractured
existences but but they're completely
different guys and from different places
and you know FBI and a new york city cop
that's about as different in the police
world as you can get I mean they I think
so uh you know that they are different
but they're they're cops and that's the
biggest similarity between the two of
them now you mention the word fractured
there and I know I'm from looking at
your own filmography and TV work and and
just having brain injuries as well I
know you love some kind of fractured
characters that you play and what is it
that attracts you about them so much
well you know they're you know they have
flaws and so flaws are human and we all
have flaws I have a lot of them I think
that's when scripts are well written
especially in in the world of television
which television is great scripts I
think you live or die at great scripts
and in the first two episodes of
crossing lines which is basically what I
had to make my decision on whether I
wanted to do the show or not Eddie
Bernero wrote wrote a character this
character of Carl Hickman by the end of
two episodes you know so much about his
world and what went wrong and you know
changed his life and sense of identity
and losing his job and how does he
handle this injury and as you take
medication for it in that and these are
all things of a guy that had a life that
was so together and you know just within
a matter of a couple of years you know
is basically his life fell apart it
really fractured and so what does that
give you
- all that stuff that makeup you know
makes up a real person and that is the
ultimate thing you know I think in the
creative journey you know I don't want
to you know play somebody that's you
know I want to play somebody who's real
and when you get great things and great
problems and it tends to make it in my
opinion somebody that's real much more
interesting for you and also for us of
course as the audience I'm you mentioned
his injury and Carl of course a bit has
been shot in the hand hasn't he I
wondered how you went about getting used
to that or how difficult either you
found getting used to that not being
able to you fit when you once in a while
well I have a glove you know it's it
takes a lot a lot of time to put on the
special effects makeup for the hand so
there's only a couple of times we've
actually seen the hand but I slide a
glove on it
once the club's on it it's it's you know
I have a reminder that I have a glove on
so I don't use my right hand every once
in a while I'll reach out for a door and
like cut you have to do that over I just
I just picked up a glass with Mike you
know Mike love's hand but uh but that's
not the fascinating thing about the hand
the fascinating thing about the hand is
that it's it's a reminder of a constant
reminder a character reminder of an
event and someone that created that
event this person that I'm trying to
find in the show it's it's a constant
reminder just sliding on that leather
glove tells me so much as the actor
about a life that has been changed
that's the importance of that and the
physical thing is not and it's it's it's
it's the mental journey it's the
emotional journey that one event had on
one person's life and went are you
mentioned of course the Prison Break
before talking about there although
they're very different characters in
different shows and they've got that
kind of forensic background that
forensic mind these characters don't
they I wondered how much or her friends
it wine did that do you have in real
life or is it rubbing off you from
playing phony characters well you know
no not that it has anything to do with
it but I when I graduated high school I
went to college I have a bachelor's I
went to school for four years I took
criminal justice I actually really
wanted to be like
in the FBI or something somewhere in the
middle of college I I partied a lot I
had a great time but that's a side note
altogether great time I can't believe it
but I made a life change switch of what
I wanted to do I wanted to be an actor
it didn't happen in high school it
didn't happen in college I took a couple
of classes but you know so I've played
so many of these guys and what I can
tell you is that it's not that they're
you know you know that they can like you
know seeing crystal balls than that you
know I think a great cop is someone it
just as a great the refined skill set
you know you if you're really good and
you really care about something and you
work hard at it you kept really good at
it
I think that's Mahone and prison-break
he's really good at it
I think Hickman is really good at being
a cop you know he knows the questions to
ask and he knows the places to look you
know everybody looks over here but he
looks over there
that's a good cop I think that's not
just unique to television I think there
are real people like that in the world
that are that good because they're great
police officers so how did it help for
example having someone like ed Bernero
obviously created the show but he's an
ex-cop himself hasn't he yeah former
Chicago police officer I think the
amazing thing about it is that you know
this is it it's the guy from the streets
of Chicago was you know a Chicago police
officer and then one day decides that
you know I want to write my stories and
it's so good I mean he's an excellent
writer I mean I mean people come from
all walks of life and do do different
things and I think that is one of those
examples of somebody Wow police officer
turns writer and is that good so he's uh
you know he he comes from a place and he
knows how to put it down on paper now
tell me about filming cuz you were
filming in Prague weren't you and you
will see for me in Paris and the South
of France it's about a very nice places
to be of doubt no doubt but I think I
think Prague has been the the jewel of
it all and and going back there to begin
this second season now
I'm not sure if I would have if I would
be in the show this year if it wasn't
going back to Prague that's how much I
love Prague so much because this isn't
sort of the sort of thing I live in
California now it isn't like I'm
travelling an hour to to go to some
location I'm travelling 10,000 miles I
wouldn't have done this if I wasn't
going with my wife from and and my kids
so you know my little ones in school
they're not I live in the Czech Republic
I live in Prague I I think of it as is
it is rapidly becoming like a second
home almost equal to the first one wow
that's great - yes I love I love love -
Czech Republic and you enjoying the be
around there all the Pilsner is just
stupid good yeah I'm a red wine drinker
and I you know III try to go to the gym
everyday you know like you know I want a
beer but you just can't stop I mean it's
it's so good it's good here in Czech
hockey I mean come on I didn't even like
beer in silhouettes Prague right I know
it's amazing
you got your Black Hawk Down buddy on
onboard as well haven't you Kim Koo Oh
Kim coches you know I told the story
many times but when I was finding out
about like how did this whole hand thing
happen with hickman and Ed and roller
were telling me all about you know well
there's this character of Jenna vase a
one day over lunch they explained like
who Genevieve day was and I told him
right then and there I just save
yourself to just hire Kim Coates right
now so they were like wow yeah we know
Kim and I'm telling you hyrum right now
and they said to me do you think he'll
do it I said he'll do it for three
reasons one you have nothing to do with
and that's because I'm here and we're
hockey fans and we and I've been telling
him about like Czech hockey and drinking
beer so he'll come over for that has
nothing to do with you you have to write
him great scenes and we won't do it and
make it worth his while and so they went
to LA this was last year and they met
him when they were there coatsy was
there a couple of months later the same
thing happened in Prison Break - you
know I remember one day I was reading
second first season I was on Prison
Break and and and I saw this I read this
breakdown of this character that comes
on and who's kind of investigating me I
called up the creators and I said get
coats right now I mean I'm shameless I
and everything I do it I read them like
you gotta get coats right now my room
right now I'm his agent I told you I
want 10% right now just keep bringing
over we're good we're big
Napa Valley red wine drinkers so I just
I tell them it's just exchange you've
got going on wine from rose I love it
now you mentioned there's already
shooting season two which is great to
hear and how would you like to see your
character developing and how would you
like to see the show developing as well
you know I love the character and I have
all faith that the character will
develop my concern is and it's not a
concern but I love does she see the show
development I want to develop you know
the first season that you do a show any
show has growing pains you know you're
figuring out you know what are you good
at what's certain things are better than
other things I'm happy to say after the
first season I really thought that the
journey that the show took was great I
mean we really came together in a way
that pretty rapidly over ten episodes
and a lot of that is behind the scenes
stuff that nobody will ever know like
watching it but but I know and I think
that you know going into a second season
I just you know explore explore the
characters because I don't think people
tune into police shows at least a show
like this for sure it's not really a
procedural show at its heart I don't
think people tune in because they don't
want to see the crime of the week I
think they want to see what these
characters are doing with the crime of
the week and the more that the
characters are explored and it's not
just a weekly thing that there are
through lines for all of the characters
and we do that that's interesting and as
long as we continue to do that I think
we've got something interesting to say
image behind the scene
some things going on there what's your
favorite behind-the-scenes story or
what's your most surprising thing that
fans would find out about the show you
know I'm always the worst at answering
those when people say to me tell me the
most funny thing that happened behind
the set I don't know I put like I put
like 9 sugars in my coffee one day and I
was like I mean I I never know I never
know I never like to me that stuff is I
don't know if it's interesting it's just
what we do you know I don't know I'll
come up with one of them if I ever think
of one I'll call you won't say I got one
I've got one I've got a great story
about your film work that you've got
coming up or thumbs that you recently
ran Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles for
example how did it go how was the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle experience
awesome absolutely awesome I remember
when my manager called me and said I got
a script and I hope you like it because
if you do you're leaving in two days to
go to New York and I'm like wow tell me
all about it he was like Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles and I'm like Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle oh wow okay because
I have nieces and nephews ten of them
that are all within that age group they
all grew up in the 80s and if you grew
up in the 80s that was the time of
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and what I
know about it you know just peripherally
is you know it always was you know
Donatello and Michelangelo and splinter
and shredder and it always had sort of a
bouncy cartoon sort of feel to me which
was great it was what it was appealing
that's not this movie this movie is
live-action Michael Bay's producing it
and I've worked with Michael a couple of
times so that's a massive commitment to
you know the visual and Jonathan
Liebesman directing it and it's it's
it's not like any Mutant Ninja Turtles
thing you've ever seen before it's it's
freaky they're cool and there are
mutants and they look awesome no it's
it's it's tough
it's gonna be really really great
fantastic I don't wait to see him and
what was it like for you playing what
must be one of the turtles most iconic
adversaries shredder yeah well I play a
guy named Eric sacks and we find out
that Eric sacks is somebody else too and
I can't give away too much in this story
but I can tell you that who shredder is
and telling of this turtles is unlike
any other telling of the story before
his connection and relationship to the
turtles is a bit surprising and really
it's for an actor playing it it was like
the backstory is which comes out and in
this film was is really really
intriguing I am intrigued no different I
mean I was - playing it I mean yeah we
made some changes while shooting the
film that I thought were just awesome
cool I mean what is it in terms of look
can you tell us a bit about what the
look is you know you know shredder is
Don's himself with armor and know and
that's who he is and that happens in
this in this story it's the backstory on
how it all began with the turtles that
the character of Eric Sachs has it isn't
by chance that he knows the turtles oh
dude I can't tell you any more right now
I'm in trouble right now would you like
to see maybe a sequel to that movie
would you like to see a Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles - it's a room for that
I'll bring for your character for that
you know all of that really happens when
in the success of the first one I mean
you know I don't want to do another one
if the first one isn't any good do I
think you're gonna see another one oh I
think you're gonna see a few of them I
do would we think we see a return for
you do you think I signed a
three-picture thing so we'll see what
happens coming up as well I'm there
already you've already brought Don st.
Sebastian in the homes but as well both
directed by and
to turn to actors Danny DeVito and Tommy
Lee Jones which maybe went
how does experience DIF a when you're
working with an actor who has turned
director as opposed to in a director who
hasn't acted before
uh you know I'm not really sure that
would be a specific case by case sort of
thing but I'd never met Tommy before and
to work with Tommy Lee Jones was and and
and I don't say this lightly or take
this for as strong as you can make these
words it was it was truly a an actor
changing experience to work with
somebody like Tommy I I never worked
with anyone that I I he is truly an
original human being and and and tough
and and I really just wanted to find
what he was looking for you got to kind
of give it up when you're around Tommy
he is uh he is the force all his own and
and in a brilliant human being and I was
amazingly proud for for something that's
you know I only worked on for a very
short time which was a life memorable
experience for sure and I think he's
going to make an unbelievable movie a
period piece from the mid 1800s it was
really something
as far as working with Danny I met Danny
1214 years ago I worked on a film called
what's the worst that could happen with
him I worked on a film called drowning
Mona with him I
I love Danny I mean let's just put it
this is how Danny came to me for Saint
Sebastian I was in in driving in New
England at seeing my son at college and
the phone rings when I'm in a rental car
driving 700 kilometers so I can go and
say hi to my sisters in Buffalo New York
and I'm driving down the New York State
Thruway and the phone rings and I'm like
all right and I like hello and he's like
hey Bill it's Danny what's happening
listen I got this movie um we have no
money I mean no listen we have no money
but it's it's cool it's care it's free
kids but uh yeah you know I mean it's
like I love I love Danny I'm like Danny
I'm thought send me I'm in I'm no I
don't even read it now I'm in
Danny I mean you're like he gets all of
these folks that he works with all the
time it's not as on to rush they all
work on it you know Tosh the DP and and
just these great people that you know
Jeffrey Carlin is one of the most
amazing costume designers you know
everybody doesn't you know we did it for
nothing I mean nothing I don't know
maybe a hundred dollars a day or
something it was it didn't matter it's
Danny what can we expect from the Saints
the best team that in your in your own
in the film well it's it's it's a crazy
spooky movie and I don't know what
Danny's and I think Danny always wanted
to have it be something that he puts out
online and so it's you know it's taken a
while because Danny came over here he
did a play so he had to kind of put the
the film on hold and and he's just put
it together and there was a screening of
it that I could not make because I was
back in Prague at the beginning of this
season so I'm not sure what the you know
what the plan is for the movie but let's
just all I want to say about Danny is
this if my phone rings right now and
he's like hey I got this idea it's crap
I'm in I'm in don't even I'm in Danny
I'm in I'll do it for the rest of my
life I'm in earlier we love to hear that
Burrell it's been absolutely lovely
talking to you thanks so much for your
time
you